you the I'm yeah
he to resist early so the BBC has just
released a new trailer for The Doctor
Who Christmas special the time at the
doctor
so that it was time to do a nice long
preview for the episode including a lot
of the information we receive since we
get the last trailer
I'm also doing in ask emergency doctor
who Q&A session later be sure to
subscribe to get it
so this will be a breakdown of all the
images in the trails at the BBC is
really so far so careful for possible is
if you wanna know anything about the
episode
first the doctor received the message
from Christmas Town the town just
happens to be on a planet called transl
or
as you heard during the first trailer as
you can see in a few the images the town
is totally decorated for Christmas
the image Akaroa in the poster holding
the turkey is from her normal Christmas
celebration with her pseudo family
we haven't seen car at home since before
the fiftieth anniversary episode
she'd actually been in any previously
but during the fiftieth anniversary
she'd started working as a teacher
it turns out the message the doctors
seed is actually a trap set by Pasha
lampley borrow a brady
who you may remember from French based
on the soldiers she's commanding in the
trailer it's possible that she could be
part love the church the doctor
encounter in the time at the Angels
or she could even be part of the
church's the silence remember during
demons run the church was working with
the head last month
and the silence this actually looks like
a continuation of that partnership to
end the doctor
don't forget the prophecy was actually
delivered by the silence and then
there's the rest at the villains
first the sounds themselves the doctor
for their plot during the wedding
River Song but the trap is set in
Christmas town looks like there could
rock the track is actually a time
dilation field whereby a small areas
trapped in a bubble up time
that moves at a much slower rate than
time outside the trap
as a result during the special the
doctor will actually age over three
hundred years
the other bills working with the sounds
in the episode include the Centaur ends
the Weeping Angels the Cybermen in the
dollar X done this kinda remind you have
the Pandorica opens
all the universe's were civilians trying
to kill the doctor
we haven't seen the sacrament in a while
remember they tend to simply things
wherever they go using the most advanced
technology available
well what do they do when they're stuck
in an all time in town the use wood
I can honestly say I never thought I
would see a wooden Cybermen
the doctor does have a few allies since
I Christmas Town there's optimal
Marta and her son Barnabas or the doctor
actually makes cost a behind in the
TARDIS so that she isn't subject to the
fact that the time trap
let's hope that it's not are molded into
becoming that wouldn't Cybermen because
the many were you at the doctor takes
along a lot of people wondered whether
or not Matt Smith was simply
agent Peter Capaldi but as you can see
in the images
he just is wearing old-age makeup and
there is a confirmed regeneration
you can even see Peter Capaldi space
blurred in the background to the poster
still though the mystery is the solution
behind the regeneration
Matt Smith is the eleventh Doctor but
he's in his 12 body
look at it this way because David
Tennant's regeneration during journeys
and counts as an actual regeneration
that doctor becomes the 11th body up the
tent doctor so Matt Smith is the 11th
doctor but he's in his 12 body
based on traditional rules he's in his
final body so he will die in this
episode unless something happens
they're too big series one includes the
cracks in the universe
remember from series 5 haven't seen a
lot of evidence to back it up
but their claim saying that the Time
Lords are responsible for the cracks
and they're going to use this somehow to
grant the doctor extra regeneration
in the final moments will call that
crack phiri then there's the possibility
that Steven Moffat could simply just
create new logic that kinda twist the
ruler 12
a call that moffett theory and I think
that is more likely
because Steven Moffat has a history a
bending Doctor Who logic without
breaking the rules a classic Doctor Who
I'm thinking that the solution will be
something that we haven't considered yet
but let me know what you think in the
comments below
what is the solution to the doctors
regeneration going to be and what are
you looking for two most in a Christmas
special
the sightseeing Peter Capaldi for the
first time I'll be doing tens more
Doctor Who videos between now and the
actual Christmas special be sure to
subscribe to get them
I'm also gonna be doing a ton of
Sherlock videos to this that she like
many sewed
coming on the twenty fifty so get
excited for that right now you can click
here to get that
ask emergency Qali the impatience is
that was the video anything click here
to get my easter egg videos for the
fiftieth anniversary there to them
thanks so much for watching a/c guys
tonight high-fives them